[Music]
the Kitzbuhel alpine rally is
celebrating its 30th anniversary this
year set in the picturesque Austrian
Alps
it's one of the most famous vintage car
events this year some 188 drivers are
taking part they're piloting 34
different brands of cars with a combined
output of over 28,000 horsepower
kitzbühel is quite a draw
as for me have this participant says
it's a special highlight in the rallying
year because here everything's right the
people the cars the atmosphere the
surroundings are fantastic the roots are
great in the organization's excellent he
can't complain because everything's
great as I thought
[Music]
this woman says they brought skis along
so if they have car troubles up in the
grouse Bruckner
they can just ski down
they're almost ready to start great
attention is being paid to all the
little last-minute details this rally is
a challenge for man or woman and machine
the key to being successful here is to
read the road book carefully and adjust
your speed accordingly it's not just the
fastest cars but the ones who maintain
the most constant speed who stand the
best chance of winning spread over three
days the race covers close to 600
kilometers at elevations of up to 2500
meters that's a real tour de force in a
1931 Bentley speed six swb this
participant says you need plenty of
upper arm strength to crank the steering
wheel and a good sense of orientation on
curves because you really can't see
where you're going will main fit this
1969 Jaguar d-type with 250 horsepower
is a famous Lamar race car the drive
along the grosse Glockner high alpine
road is a highlight of this year's rally
its serpentine curves demand a lot from
both drivers and their cars
seven decades of automotive history are
on display at the kitzbühel alpine rally
pre-world War two models elegant sports
coupe A's and 1950s and 60s sedans can
be seen alongside sports cars and rare
newer models the touring cars race cars
stunning sedans and convertibles attract
the most attention these vehicles
designs were chosen for their appeal
rather than their aerodynamics
[Music]
this rare model is making a rare
appearance in Kitzbuhel a 1936
rolls-royce phantom 3 but the 170
horsepower phantom runs into some
problems its owner says nothing's
happened it's just quite hot in the
routes very steep he says like him the
car is an old man it's 80 he 70 it's
never let him down but today it's got a
little overheated once it cools down he
says it'll start purring again and it's
always been a rolls-royce philosophy to
have a tool on hand to suit every
situation after a bit of help getting up
the gross Glock 9 the rolls with its
displacement of 7.4 liters is back in
business and can continue on its journey
after three days in which the cars have
covered close to 600 kilometers it's the
final spurt the drivers can't afford to
make a mistake now if they want to end
up in the final rankings and they've
done it they've reached the finish line
motor sports fans have gathered on Kitts
pools main square to welcome the drivers
and applaud their efforts why the
kitzbühel rally have you looked at the
weather have you look at the mountains
have you met the people it's a perfect
place to go driving
[Music]